It was after ten days of walking in nature
in silence on a meditation retreat
and stepping into an area
that was so pure and tender
that it really felt like no person stepped there
for a very long time or even forever.
And when I stepped there,
the first thought that came to my mind
was questioning whether I have a right to be there,
stepping in a place full of living organisms
thriving there without any human interference.
And then the next thought was,
"What if I was a cow?"
You know, then it would be very natural
for me to walk there.
These very different questions
and these very different ways of looking at myself
walking in the world in a very certain moment
really made me question the whole assumptions
of how we, people, walk on Earth
and work on Earth
and thrive on Earth.
And is there really such a big difference
between the way we view animals
and the way we walk ourselves?
And maybe this inspiration
to how we as designers, as creative people,
as people that are willing to question
everything around us
and find new ways,
is very much about agreeing to walk like cows
and agreeing to be part of this wealth
of living organisms.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.